[Music]
welcome to the DS show we have a lot to
talk about today you know there's been
over a hundred eighty thousand plus
murders since 9/11 Americans killin
Americans how many of those have been
Muslims we're going to be talking about
that and this year alone over three
hundred fifty six mass killings
shootings two of those again linked back
to somebody who calls himself a Muslim
and where's the third shooter re San
Bernardino police have confirmed that
indeed it was three shooters that they
thought three men with what appeared to
be long rifles you're certain that you
saw three men yeah yeah white where I
was at right here we've seen now there
was three white men in military fatigues
all this and more this on this week's
showed the DS show don't go anywhere
we'll be right back
[Music]
welcome back to the D show professor how
are you peace be with you Salam alaykoum
well professor Omar it's a great to have
you on a Dean show great to be here
there's a lot of crazy things going on
and and it's very sad
you know we're here things are just
constantly developing we're gonna get
right straight into it I obviously we
have no sympathy nor do we sympathize
with people who hurt innocent people
it's very clear in Islam I mean this is
something that anyone who reads the you
know idiots book to understanding Islam
can figure this one out but recently
there was this um out of the 300 I
believe 56 mass shootings this year even
one is too many
yeah and I want to take you now to
because this goes to the one of those
from the 356 that's linked to it from
the news reports many people are just
wondering what happened here I'm gonna
ask you about that after we watch this
clip let's do it re San Bernardino
police have confirmed that indeed it was
three shooters and that they have indeed
left in a black SUV before it was a
little bit unclear whether it was one
two or three shooters the police are
saying that yes it was three shooters
but the reason they believe that there
are three individuals is because
witnesses told police that they saw
three men with what appeared to be long
rifles leaving that scene it was I just
saw three dressed exactly the same
you're certain that you saw three men
yes it looks like they're calling yeah
white they look like they were athletic
bills
and they appears to be tall you're
certain that you saw three men yes it
looks like they're calling yeah white
they look like they were athletic bill
and they appeared to be tall where I was
at right here we've seen there was three
white men in military fatigues the way
they were driving yeah and it just
doesn't make sense
for for these two to be able to act like
some kind of Bonnie and Clyde or
something it's just ridiculous it it
doesn't add up
witnesses told police that they saw
three men with what appeared to be long
rifles leaving that theme there's
there's a lot of disconnects and there's
a lot of unknowns and there's a lot of
things that quite frankly don't add up
or seem implausible where I was at right
here we've seen there was three white
men in military fatigues okay we got to
see I mean this is major media now
reporting as it's actually happening the
witnesses are coming out now we know I
mean usually in these government
buildings and these institutions there's
cameras all over the place and I don't
know if there was at that institution
but open and shut for us is I mean it's
pretty clear again we don't sympathize
with anybody who's has such extreme
ideology Islam doesn't teach it preached
it there's no discussion about it but
obviously if these witness are saying
look we saw the brown skin you know you
know a man with a woman with hijab scarf
whatever the case she was about I think
90 to 100 pounds they're saying three
white athletic tall there's a disparity
here well I mean what do you have to say
video comments on it so first it's an
open investigation right and and we have
to wait to see how things play out you
did make this point that there must be
cameras right and so the cameras would
be investigated to see all right who's
on the scene how many people right what
we should then too
explore all the different options
without intruding upon the
investigations like those reporters date
who went into into the the alleged
shooters house and and just ransacked
the entire apartment you know for the
sake of ratings so on the one hand there
is still this big question if there were
three shooters as different people have
said in in the clip that you showed San
Bernardino police have confirmed that
indeed it was three shooters that they
thought three men with what appeared to
be long rifles you're certain that you
saw three men yeah yeah white where I
was at right here we've seen now there
was three white men in military fatigues
that means there's a third shooter on
the loose right now from the perspective
of law enforcement they're also watching
all this and they're also well aware of
that and they're also gonna be
calculated in terms of what they share
with us right but the bottom line is
that it raises a question yeah on the
flip side suppose three people thought
that they saw three shooters and it was
just these two then it raises a
different set of really hard questions
what is it that could compel a father or
especially a mother to abandon their
baby I mean the bottom line is that this
this whole event as well as what people
have witnessed as well as what is the
official story it raises a lot of very
very tough questions that have to be
addressed you definitely have to be
really sick and deranged
I mean you you've actually been studying
Islam your professor of Islam at the
university you teach it I said someone
who just picks up the idiots guide to
understand Islam I mean it's pretty
clear in Islam the do's and don'ts and
what will win you pleasure of the
creator and paradise you do not have a
one this is a one way ticket to the
Hellfire doing something like this
absolutely leaving your child I mean I
just it's for many it's it's like what
would caught you there Islam doesn't
teach you this what do you think well I
mean I've been working for for some time
in what is now called countering violent
extremism or accounting countering
targeted violence and I've had the the
opportunity to talk to some people who
had already gone
in trouble and there are a few common
factors that are easy to identify after
the fact one is is just a deep amount of
anger the anger could be related to
what's happening with Muslims in the
world more often it's related to
something that's happening into a
personal person's house another common
issue is a very very simplistic
understanding of very complex issues and
so our Deen our religion is very very
simple in terms of what is Haram what is
halal right but in terms of applying
those passages that speak about violence
that speak about fighting there are a
number of passages that are part of the
book they are the truth and but you
can't just haphazardly try to implement
them right and also very simplistic
understanding of how the world works
there's a mistaken notion that okay I
can just go shoot this and then I've
done a victory for for God but even if
we to look at 9/11 is more than 1300
architects and engineers examine the
evidence about building sevens collapse
and disagree with the official report
issued by the National Institute of
Standards and Technology
I certainly am much more open-minded
about it than I was and it is because of
the involvement of the 9/11 families and
all these engineers and architects you
are about to hear from architect of 23
years richard gage AIA remember the
american institute of architects and
founder of architects and engineers for
9/11 truth now there are more than 1500
architects and engineers who say that it
could not have been brought down by
office fires they are backed by 9/11
family members who are calling for an
independent unbiased investigation i'm a
family member trying to find out the
answers to the murder of three
thousand-plus people
the bottom line is that it needs to be
investigated properly
please architects and engineers
people all around the world scientists
all around the world are questioning
this then there's some deep deep
explaining to do some kind of
consciousness-raising on my part before
I was willing to look at the the
possibilities and really you need to go
where the evidence leads as an engineer
I have three degrees in engineering I
signed that petition for architects and
engineers for 9/11 truth some time ago
because the American people absolutely
need the truth of 9/11 look at the
evidence in fact I'll say this very
categorically any reasonable person who
looks at the evidence that's been
brought forward has got to come away
with the feeling that something has to
be done a real investigation has to be
put forward
we will never heal this country will
never ever ever forget that day we have
to demand a new investigation I want
justice here
if we have Muslims who are who would be
destroying these buildings in America
what was the end result the Iraq gets
obliterated Afghanistan gets obliterated
and its justification for this gigantic
so-called war on terror right third
issue is a type of romanticism where
people believe that they are superheroes
the and they can come in and save the
day
and what I've just described for you
seems to be consistent in many of these
these young people but what I've also
described for you is I think every other
teenager and so the way I framed this
this problem of people who are attracted
to you to what is today Isis what was
yesterday al-qaeda and tomorrow who
knows what will be some people to to
deal with their their angst they go to
drugs some people go to boyfriend or
front some people go to other bad habits
or bad crowd and now there's this crop
of people who go to this in in the
Muslim community but go to go to the
American South and those people go to to
you know white supremacist militias the
hard part is figuring out who's the one
who's going to go in that direction but
nevertheless a point that I make to many
people is that okay Isis exists today if
there's an Islamic connection why didn't
I see success 100 years ago that if
Islam is a cause and the point being in
fact Islam is somewhere in there or what
people want to call Islam was in there
somewhere
but so is geopolitics you have the
former military chief who's saying that
the Iraq war was a failure I mean and he
talks about the the point I want to
focus here is that that that helped
create Isis and many of the generals and
people in authority are saying that you
know this this was something like you're
saying talking about geopolitical and
actually this is this with a vacuum
effect mm-hmm meaning the best group to
look at in recent history to get a sense
of Isis today or what Isis is supposed
to be today is to go back to Cambodia
and Vietnam a few decades ago and look
at this group called the Khmer Rouge
there's a whole oscar-winning movie
about it called The Killing Fields and
what was taking place there
we the United States we're fighting the
Soviets and one of the grounds for that
fight was Southeast Asia and when people
left
you had the Khmer Rouge who came in who
were hardcore communist and they're
wiping everyone out by today's language
by the sword
there's killing everybody in their way
Isis is very much as far as we know
something very similar to that and
eventually they themselves were wiped
out and then of course in in Muslim
history we have the hawala CH which were
these groups of ultra militant
literalists who were even foreshadowed
by the Prophet peace be upon him and who
committed violence against the beloved
companions and the family of the Prophet
peace be upon him may God be pleased
with them but the point is that these
groups don't exist in a vacuum they
exist in an environment where some
people go in and take advantage and
other people they they have no clue of
what better to do yeah we're gonna take
a break going off that there's also
right now media I mean it's not you
haven't even heard of these but they're
doing an ethnic cleansing right now in
the Central African Republic have you
heard of these ever a little bit yeah
yeah but you don't hear about it they're
killing thousands I mean thousands of
people you don't hear about this stuff
we're gonna take a break and put things
when we come back into perspective give
you some facts not fiction you've heard
the stereo the the the saying not all
how does it go not all Muslims are
terrorists broad Tara's are Muslims
others we're gonna let the numbers speak
okay we'll be right back Hannity show
Professor Omar don't want any we're
right back as nothing to do with my
prophet please just stop it
it doesn't make any sense that's not the
message he sent that's not what he meant
that's not why he came so you can claim
as much as you want to but I assure you
the man I follow was not the same see I
know a man who forbade the cutting down
of a plan
who even spoke against those who had
birth and aunt so why is it that I
simply can't understand how we claim to
follow the same man I mean I know a man
forbade us from harming the innocent
saying he who does so would not only be
prohibited from paradise but he would
not even smell its scent so please tell
me how what you're doing has anything to
do with the message that he sent this is
the man who forbade us from even scaring
cattle with a knife saying you have no
right to let the animal da twice and
when he was asked for advice he'd reply
don't get angry don't get angry don't
get angry repeating it thrice please
subscribe to the DCO follow us on our
official Facebook and Twitter pages in
the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show now when I had
started we talked about just this year
alone so we put things in perspective
because the media is making it seem like
the only people that are crazy out there
are the Muslims right and we know that a
Muslim is simply one who submits to the
will of God any peaceful person who
submits to one God the same God that
Jesus Moses Abraham peace be upon them
all who they call people to submit
that's the one God and a Muslim
it's an ox you can't be one who submits
to the will of God trying to please God
you kill innocent people
the doesn't work but now let's I wanted
to share without our audience the
numbers you know they don't lie you you
had just in this country alone 356 mass
murders that have happened two of those
one is is just too many all right you
had from 1980 to 2005 you had the FBI
data reports showing that now from all
these years that only six percent had
any links to Islam ninety four percent
were people who had nothing to do with
Islam then you had the Euro poll from
2006 to 2007 again putting things
in perspective 1% link back to anything
with Islam hundred get this professor
180,000 Americans killed by other
Americans since 9/11 and only 30 I think
it was around close to 40 were Muslim
right what do you when you hear these
when people see that when you put this
in perspective people don't usually see
these numbers right but now when they
see him I mean what do you what do you
take when you hear this
well I'm because I'm already familiar
with these numbers and because I'm a
Muslim grew up in America the numbers
are more surprising just because of how
many people are getting killed in
America right killing is not part of our
conversation protecting ourselves from
getting killed as part of our
conversation but that's because of
handgun violence that's taking place by
anybody right I think there are a few
points that have to be brought to our
attention one is that by and large Islam
is deterrent for violence rather than a
contributor to violence no doubt there
are people who believe that committing
violence is the Islamic way and it's
hard to find a person who is like that
unless they've already gotten caught
right the other issue the bigger issue
for us as Muslims in America is to
figure out how do we respond to all this
so what you're doing right now is a very
good step to show that the facts don't
line up and the big question is where do
we go from here if we look at the
history of Islam in America not only do
we find that we're not violent we find
that we were part of the whole growth
and development of America you and I are
here in Chicago Sears Tower which is now
called the Willis Tower the John Hancock
building were designed by the Muslim the
most famous boxer of the mall was a
Muslim right even when the most famous
jazz musicians I mean this is off the
topic and John Coltrane he was a Muslim
and the point that I'm making is that
what we have to do as Muslims is not
only show how important we are in
building America I mean consider how
many physicians in Chicago or how many
cab drivers in Chicago are are Muslim
and then take that model and then figure
out how to fix these problems in society
while people are blaming
while people are throwing rocks at us
our approach should be that we will
continue to feed them
and we will continue to build this
country because this is our home that is
very much what we find in the tradition
of Islam throughout history going back
to the Prophet peace be upon him and
from Empire to end part two Empire
taking what is great about a nation and
then figuring out how to make it even
better I want to take you to a clip so
again very disturbing to hear yeah I get
you take on more good people had
concealed carry permits then we could
end those Muslims before they before
they walk down killer yeah it's uh that
wasn't statement by the the current
president of Liberty University Jerry
Falwell jr. the son of Jerry Falwell was
passed away
and I mean people are always panicking
pointing fingers at how Islam is being
misused Christianity is what's being
misused Christianity is being used to to
convince people to to arm themselves and
be ready to kill if needed and show me
where that is in the Gospels in in in
Christianity it's definitely not there
in in the Islamic narrative on Jesus
peace be upon him and it's definitely
out there in the Christian narrative on
Jesus but you have people who who
believe that that is not only the
American Way but the Christian Way and I
think as a Muslim I'm offended for
Christianity that that's happening and
to take this point a step further what
is it that's motivating this I think
what's motivating this is some very deep
deep fear that why would somebody arm
themselves they're afraid of something
it's not macho to be able to kill
someone
it's the Prophet peace be upon was
reported to tell it to tell us that the
strong is not the one who can knock
someone down the strong is the one who
can control himself and in you and I as
Muslims in society have to figure out
how to cure this fear that's taking
place as leading people to behave in the
most ridiculous ways I think that you
know people such as the Farwell
gentleman
would probably fall under the latest
numbers the the study that was done and
again these are the date the data is
showing by a homeland security report
that the greatest threat to America is
the domestic threat of far-right
radicals I mean they did a get another
study and they show that 50 percent of
Republicans say dismantle the
Constitution and make the Christian
Sharia mm-hmm have you heard these
numbers I've heard I don't recall the
numbers 57 percent of Republicans
according to a new poll say dismantle
the Constitution we need Christianity as
our national religion religion now this
might come as a shock to you because we
are seeing people are seeing it now I
mean this is the reports I mean here
here again we are we're living in
Chicago my father he was walking out of
fudger prayer early in the morning in
Orland Park he didn't notice his until
on the news but while he was walking out
somebody shot at the dome of the mosque
and that later on that day in the local
shopping mall the cars were plastered
with ads for the KKK KKK is a far bigger
threat in Chicago than than than Isis
this is Orland Park here in Chicago this
happened one this happened March of I
think 2050 or 14 I believe yeah and so
we do have to be honest about where the
problems are and and we can't get
ourself distracted from from all these
other things that the news wants to talk
about cuz it'll get radiance and you and
I have the responsibility for fixing it
I mean I usually tell people when we say
again that's another hype that's created
around the word Sharia Sharia is obvious
I said Christians should hear because
that's what they want to implement
Sharia obviously came to protect life so
anytime you see life being taken
something in just no no should he has
the 10 commandments whatever the
prophets brought that's just a law of
God and it's put to preserve life yeah I
intentionally didn't use the word Sharia
just like I don't use the word jihad in
those ways because I just find a
repulsive because this is a sacred
uplifting a concept and even if people
want to misuse it I think it's
inappropriate there yeah yeah we're
going to take a break professor we'll be
right back with more here on the D
show Rebecca so what is it that we still
don't understand when we claim to follow
Islam yeah we fail to follow this man I
mean I know a man who was so caring and
compassionate who said that there is a
reward in serving all things that are
animal in other words everything that
breathes whether it be the animals the
trees and every single human being
I mean if Allah called him Rafi maternal
I mean how dare you call him anything
else that contravenes see this is a man
who said that the Muslim was he who was
soft simple and lenient a man who taught
us himself to be cautious from falling
into extremism see he was never given
two choices except he chose that which
was easiest not for himself but for his
people and their convenience see I know
a man who advocated for the freedom of
the slaves a man who taught us that the
Muslim is the one from whom the people
are safe not only from his hands but
even from the words that he says see
this is a man who would never mock mimic
nor ridicule nobody ever publicly
rebuked an individual this is the man I
follow so forgive me if this sounds
unusual but the man I know was so much
more handsome so beautiful
please subscribe to the diva follow us
on our official Facebook and Twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the DS show with Professor Omar
tell us I'm gonna take you to another I
liked this statement it talks about
listen to this this is mr. Johnston from
the Secretary of Homeland Security
talking about give the Muslims a larger
platform take it away
I'm asking them to partner with
community leaders in the Muslim
community to give them a larger platform
for their message to give them a larger
platform and a larger microphone for the
counter message Wow did you hear that I
mean they're giving Isis my guest come
out
Khalil meek was on the show and he said
something really I mean that carries a
lot of weight so he said that the the
media today is like almost recruiting
for Isis you know constantly giving them
the platform but you see what the the
gentleman said mm-hmm what do you think
so
I'll give you a positive and a negative
a positive is that the Council of
Islamic organization of Chicago actually
said this to Homeland Security and to
the FBI that you're using these methods
of entrapment you're using these these
very inappropriate unethical methods why
don't you work with us because we know
the community and we care about the
community and we don't want our young
people to get in trouble and so we have
been working with them to figure out how
to how to cure some of the things that
would lead to these problems the
negative is that it also puts the burden
of responsibility on us to find to seek
out criminals and the point being that
looking at the the stats that you that
you that you provided within the Muslim
community or within American society
so-called Islamic radicalization is a
tiny problem you look at the media you
think it's the biggest problem the world
and and so yes we as Muslims should be
responsible for our own communities and
we are but the negative is that we have
a bigger problem of Muslims leaving
Islam we have a bigger problem of
domestic violence we have a bigger
problem that's just within the Muslim
community but in terms of Greater
Chicago Society of American society the
problem of violence in Chicago the
problem
hunger in Chicago is much much more of a
priority as far as I'm concerned than
so-called Islamic radicalization yeah I
mean if you give us the platform let's
say for example I mean they put the Deen
show on one of these major networks and
let us get the message out right one of
the probably the only Islamic talk shows
in America I mean I mean so now or
bringing on people like yourself people
were out there the leaders in the
community and let them speak on what
Islam is and what Islam isn't and let us
have that platform I mean I think that's
great what he's saying instead of just
promoting pumping up Isis like as if
they represent Islam but that's all the
people are seeing it 24/7 and then the
average layman thinks that this is these
are the you know Muslims the boogeyman
coming to get you it's like KKK being
pumped up all day and night as if this
represents Christianity yeah and if the
KKK was getting covered it would get a
lot more membership and then building
upon what you're saying we start with
speaking about what Islam is and what
isn't and then way as you and I live
what Islam is and isn't then we will see
not only a change in how people look at
Muslims but we will see a change in
society because we'll be doing our job
where I live in Chicago I live in the
south side of Chicago and my wife and I
we often say that as far as Muslims are
concerned we live in the safest
neighborhood in all of Chicago it's
almost entirely african-american and the
history of Islam in the african-american
community regardless of issues of
problematic theology the history of
Islam in the African community is that
it's something that presented itself is
something that's improving the lives of
people that's improving Society and so
if people understand that to be what
Islam is then everyone is gonna love it
even if they don't become Muslim I mean
nobody bullying is an epidemic today
yeah amongst kids but I think we're
seeing it with adults now I mean you see
Muslims who are the most if you look the
numbers don't lie some of the most
peaceful the most charitable the most
hospitable people in the world and would
you say now with all of this
Islamophobia rising I mean instead of
coming up to your neighbor and talking
to him say look I heard this stuff on
the news can you tell me about Islam do
you really believe talk let's open up
absolutely people are doing some heinous
demonic take things I mean this is
bullying worse than that what do you
think yeah the fuel of bullying is anger
and when
the most frightening chapters in the
Quran comes at the very end it's about
this gentleman of love who was named in
that the father of the flame because he
had a fiery temper and he even looked
like he was always angry and anger
destroys of that surah speaks about how
his anger destroyed himself just
destroyed his is his wife because she
was feeling the fire and and he's one of
the few people spoken of in the quran is
going straight to paradise and so we
have to figure out how to cure this
anger that's taking place and i'm
suggesting that the fuel of this anger
is just fear and if a person can reach a
point that they are comfortable that God
will take care of them no matter what
struggles they get hit that will cure
much of the fears about you he went
straight to that what to the Hellfire
mm-hmm oh yeah tell us
Sheikh do you think now look with all
what's going on I mean there's got to be
light at the you know these women out
there who are just trying to follow the
way of Jesus's mother Mary modesty
they're trying to be a good noble
character they're not talking about
leaving their babies behind and doing
some crazy for that demonic thing that
will actually be a straight one way
ticket to the Hellfire I mean this is
something that Islam does not condone it
condemns with no no ambiguity there I
mean but now they're being harassed you
see all these reports you know is there
light at the end of the tunnel what
someone's like you know what do we do so
in the short term a person has to keep
him or herself safe right it's a reality
that people are getting harassed people
are getting assaulted and we keep
hearing these stories that people are
actually getting killed so it's a real
problem
people have to keep themselves
themselves safe in terms of the long
term there were even points where the
prophets peace be upon them said when is
the help of God coming and in an
important point here is that we all know
that the help of God is coming and we
also know guaranteed from God that he's
never going to give us anything we can't
handle
so the point we have to do is first turn
back to God and remind ourselves that
all right there's chaos in the world and
Cass is going to happen my job is to
keep moving forward and things will
change
let's end off on a good note I heard a
story and before you get into that I
think open houses are just a phenomenal
way to make
human connection me and my good friend
dr. Sabeel we were hosting and we were
at a Masjid a mosque and the commander
was there the mayor came we had
community leaders from other churches
they came in priest was there and they
got to ask questions and we were we got
to express with them share with them
what Islam is about what it's not about
they got it was they got to ask
questions it was amazing you know they
left they were just with positive
feedback I think every must just should
be inviting their neighbors to come in
not to be kind of just excluded and just
you know disconnected what do you think
with it yeah I think the during prayer
time the mall should be full
outside of prayer time the mall should
potentially be empty not because
everyone's at home but because
everyone's out building connections
building relationships and building
their community and in building society
to make our society wherever we are
whether we're in Chicago or New York or
Karachi or or even in Rhodesia
what-have-you that the point is that we
are building and we're building through
connections give us this you know I even
I mean I'm telling you people who had
who were the worst enemies to Islam they
became people who started to love it
there's so many examples of this once
the human connection was made and then
once they really saw what Islam is about
you have one of those
always tell us about I've got I've got
plenty of stories one is is a friend or
student of mine who 9/11 he was a
college student when 9/11 happened he
wanted blood he wanted Muslim blood
super ultra far right winger that was
September of 2001 he started learning
about Islam started studying Islam in
May 2002 he became Muslim and I can give
you plenty of examples like that that
the point for us is that you can't ever
give up hope in God which means you
can't give up hope
yeah we don't even give up hope in these
people or bullying our heart is open I
mean Islam is open to everybody and
let's end on that good note thank you
god bless you and thank you for tuning
in we covered a lot in this episode of
the D shall put things in perspective I
mean just one as the Quran says killing
one innocent being is as if you killed
the entire humanity saving one is if you
save the entire human
there's no religious book out there that
makes this point very clear
and a messenger who was sent as a mercy
to all of mankind who prohibited the
killing of innocent men women children
people in places of worship and this is
one of the first crimes that is going to
be people are going to be accountable
for when they have innocent blood on
their hands
so no Muslim who is truly submitting to
the Creator that happen to earn the same
God that Jesus worship because you can't
be a Muslim unless you love and revere
Jesus and all the messages that the
Creator sent calling people to worship
the Creator not the creation and to be
on the highest level the highest summit
of best manners and character to be best
to your neighbors to be a asset to
society making the world that we live in
a better place not spreading corruption
and hate through the world and we put
things in perspective that 356 mass
shootings have happened just this year
alone more than the number of day just
one is horrific enough and then we asked
like what's going on we have no sympathy
for anyone who takes one innocent life
who hurts innocent people now we're
asking a question where is the tall
athletic I mean they ask this is what
the witnesses were saying we got to go
ahead and discuss this and we talked
about the hundred eighty thousand plus
murders that have happened since 9/11
and a handful of those have been
perpetrated by those again who are
Muslim but look at it in its perspective
and then we talked about the data
reports from the FBI Homeland Security a
Europol 1% linked back to anybody of
terrorism with Islam and also the 94%
nothing to do with being a Muslim or
Islam so it's very clear the numbers
don't lie there they're Muslims are the
most peaceful hospitable people today
but we're being bullied you have a lot
of people out there now who are taking
this opportunity they have this agenda
to try to go ahead and the fame Aslam
and Muslims but humanity people of
consciousness need to come up and many
are our brothers
humanity who are striving towards peace
towards a better tomorrow need to come
up and condemn these acts this bullying
this terrorism that's happening towards
Muslims who are law-abiding citizens who
are working towards establishing peace
in their lives peace with their Creator
and peace with humanity who don't we're
not talking about hurting anybody taking
innocent life no way anybody who reads a
simple book like a Complete Idiot's
Guide to understanding Islam will tell
you that so at the end of the day you've
gotten to see things in perspective no
sympathy for anyone who hurts innocent
people and many of these things are
political geopolitical have nothing to
do with the teachings of Islam and the
good people out there the people whose
hearts are alive can see this and we
need more people like that to step up to
rise up and to condemn these acts these
KKK types to have more in common with
the Isis and the daesh you are out there
spreading this hate don't stand for it
condemn it be a voice against it and
let's work together to make this
community this world this place that we
live in a place of peace and harmony by
creating this understanding so we can
live together as brothers and sisters in
humanity we'll see you next time until
then peace be with you Sami please
subscribe to the Biggio follow us on our
official Facebook and Twitter pages in
the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below